how are you friends from facebook and
social networks I am your friend cristian
casa de disney and disney in spanish and
well we are here connecting with
you completely live from the
illuminated studios here in las vegas
to give you a preview of what is
happening in  the capital of the country in the
capital in the capitol now in
washington
we are right now in
what is the
control room here for the newscast and
basically this is where
the images are coming to
us are impressive images that have been coming to us
for a few hours when  All this
began through a demonstration
that was taking place in the capital and
pure people who are in favor of the
president of tam oxford and out of nowhere they
rushed to the capitol and it is at
this moment where
different images are arriving as I imagine the
they are seeing through our
social networks of twitter of facebook and well
these people that we know reasons
thousand  s of people who have actually
come here
and we know that they have already entered
the capitol building we know that the police
the police local and also
federal officials are there doing what they
can trying to stop these
people who for some reason
others who are  doing basically
everything possible to get closer and get
inside the capital we know who at
that time this morning members
of the senate of congress were
basically in a meeting trying to
officially give a tally of the votes
to officially declare the president-
elect I stop as the winner of  the
elections but because of this
demonstration there is this incident because
all that apparently came to a pause
we know that the members of the
senate apparently most of them are
fine many of them are following
their accounts on social networks and they
are publishing that  they
are in a
safe place and away from all the chaos that is
going on  right now at this moment
we are also following the account of the
president of donald trump that he is
telling all his followers that
they please remain
peaceful and raising their voice but
peacefully and also obeying the
local authorities which is simply
of noticing
favoring what he was seeing no
type of violent act and he is asking
all the people to basically
remain calm and to do it in a
peaceful way as well as you can see we
are getting images inside and
outside what is the capitol in  washington
dc and well they are very
impressive images as you can imagine
we also have reports of
people walking into the capitol
with flags some armed people
and well we are following the
different
lines of information that are
reaching our newsroom and
is the information that we are publishing
for you through our
home pages  and also on our
social media pages so
lots of information a very busy day
but we are also asking you
to please stay connected with
us so that you are always up to date with
what is happening not
only here in las vegas but also
in  the capital of the country so if
you have any kind of question
please send your comments and
we will do everything possible to be able to with
[Music]
as you can see right now this
demonstration continues right now
in the capital of the country washington de
señorita is a place  very busy we know
that the authorities are there
basically taking care of ski ski
in the capitol
we know that the protesters again
managed to enter the capitol we know that
the local and federal authorities
are there making a presence trying to
keep these people calm
that apparently
was basically  because of a
demonstration in favor of the president of
trump that was organized  They were in the city and from
there they went to the capitol
many of them we can see that they
have flags they also have the
miami caps change carl craig into and
they continue shouting singing that the
president of trump is the winner
of last month's elections  November
so a lot of information about what
is coming to us at this moment
here in the reaction room of Luis Grau
and the Spanish neon gray and we ask you
to please continue with us connected
on social networks as always
so that you always  keep up to date
with all the information